so start so I'm not the sheriff this is
my chance and I usually talk quickly
about we have a website for open
problems now so the URL is open and up
in the corner now so it just has a list
of open problems that you can look at
and comment on me if you're signed in
and see comments too and then if you
want to submit note for a problem you
can get the text file to submit on this
page i looks lead you to a page where
you can download the text file and then
email your PDF to either mark 4i
[Music]
okay so doing an open problem session
now we have nine speakers lined up each
of which have at most eight minutes to
present an open problem
so by setup
okay so a.m.
thanks the organizer for inviting me and
there I'm happy to be here with my first
baby to our privacy workshop conference
I don't know yes so this is the so we'll
present an open problem which is also a
promo for my Friday talk so in the in
fact on Friday I will discuss some
partial progress in this direction and
this is based on joint work with no
baloney obscured or Olivia Morgan to
Mary Alice and last year in Princeton
and one nice thing it was that I had
working with these people with that I
really realized that the depth of the
mathematical depth of privacy so mary
anti-malaria see the model theories she
deal with very large infinities and no
need to compute or at least and then
more computer science okay so one basic
theorem in statistical learning so I
will explain this projection of
learnable classes of horrible problems
and it shows you basically that Unicom
convergence i will explain all this
later is so these implications are
trivial
you know convergence applies proper
learning implies learning but the fact
that they are all equivalent which is
which also manifests very basic
principles in learning so for example
the equivalence between these two guys
is known as the ERM principle is a
manifestation of the ERM principle but
it although through a mathematical
parameter called the VC dimension and
you know this result which was
accumulated by several authors is also
called the fundamental theorem back
turning so it's really one of the basics
back you learn in any statistical
learning class and what we want
basically or conjecture is a private
or just added private in front of any
any of the statistical properties of
learning and I changed the VC dimension
by a built on dimension which as we fill
up full half time is an adapted version
of VC dimension so let me first just
explain what these relations are what is
what is supervised learning without
privacy so we have some domain X we have
a semi Porter this class just functions
from it 0 1 and we have some unknown
distribution on examples we get to see a
bunch of examples
iid sample from the distribution for
example there is a bit indicating T
value label and our goal is to output
our and I posted this which minimizes
the expected loss and then the nonlinear
part is that this loss average is
unknown is the probability according to
the unknown distribution of having the
disagreement and this is so you minimize
an unknown quantity what you do know so
the population loss is unknown what you
do know is them curriculars and ok so
this is the learning framework now we
have these definitions uniform
convergence learning etc so what does
uniform convergence say it says that if
you see enough examples you see a fire
disciples then for every hypothesis in
the class the empirical loss which you
know will be roughly the same like the
true loss okay so what you see what you
get the empirical loss is like is
roughly the true loss simultaneously for
each photo this in the class
Unicom conversion the nobility tells you
that you can basically minimize the true
lost no finite sample so there exist
some bounds implicit bounty if you can
see that many examples then this
algorithm based on the sample output
some hypothesis which minimizes or
competes with the best position class
and proper learning also requires that
the output equalities is always in the
class in H now it's clear that and the
last thing is the VC dimension which ok
this is this parameter I will explain it
more on Friday for now just think of
which is the community total parameter
but it's clear that uniform convergence
implies proper learning right if what
you see is what if all empirical assists
are like the true law says just pick the
empirical risk minimizer this will also
be an approximate population loss
minimizer and of course if you can learn
properly then can also learn improperly
just an extra constraint and these three
things are equivalent via this notion of
VC dimension so now we have private
analogs so what is private Unicom
convergence it's the same thing like
uniform convergence only that I require
it to happen privately so what what do I
mean so you get to see a sample from the
population distribution an ID sample and
now you want to publish in a private
manner another sample so T is another is
a new sample which is published
privately and you want that again all
the losses with respect to T will be
close to the true losses so this is very
close to synthetic data and sanitization
and of course once you have private unit
from convergence you have private proper
learning because you can just post
process it with any erm not necessarily
private so the similar phenomena like in
in the classical place and traffic
learning is just like learning but you
want to be algorithm will be private
proper private learning is also the
output is in the class and then there is
Nielsen dimension which is an adaptive
version of the business dimension so
before these decision trees had the same
forever each layer now it's different
and let me just finish with again with
the open problem
so we're yeah so we conjecture or my
conjecture that this equivalence holds
and we know some parts we know this
direction so in August every frog the
learnable class has a finite VC
dimension and we also know that private
popular name is equivalent to private
elephant convergence and I will discuss
this on Friday and let me just mention
that whilst on dimension is deeply
related to all that learning so there is
also a mysterious connection which comes
up in the proof that I will show between
online learning and try to see which is
natural but still it still is I don't we
don't understand it questions first shy
about to tell us up
why do you define privacy as replacing s
with t and not you could also just say
that the whole life a thesis is is
private relative to the sample set learn
from that the learner is private no
certainty was in the context of uniform
convergence so now the goal is to
publish all ourselves of all hypotheses
in the class and one natural way to
encode it is by a sample T but you can
also so this is synthetic data it would
also talk about sanitization and then
you can somehow encode it in a different
way but since here we just talked about
statistical complexity so it's
equivalent I don't care about
computational complexity so if I
understood correctly it's sufficient to
show that if you've got finally
Littlestone dimension and there's a
proper private property under s it's
efficient so the question is sufficient
like it would be enough to show to solve
the open question yeah to show that if
it has finite little stuff little stone
dimension L then that conceptual
complexity is sufficient for like proper
learning as opposed to for uniform
private uniform convergence so we do
aren't those equivalents already higher
yeah
[Music]
hi I'm Batali so I'm going to talk about
to talk about about something else on
Thursday and it's a different topic and
the talk on Thursday will also have open
problems so if you want more there will
be more on Thursday so this open problem
is related to a model of private
learning that came out of recent joint
paper with Cynthia and it's actually
relatively new open problem so it might
be actually pretty easy to solve they
don't know
so the basic motivation for this for
this model is the sort of the
observation that the utility privacy
trade-off in in the sort of usual way we
learn where you release the model with
differential privacy is not so great and
we now have both empirical evidence for
this and also theoretical bounds where
you often have to pay for the dimension
but at the same time in many settings
sort of the users of the of these models
only need to see predictions they don't
need to see models for example if I am
if I go into say a hospital I want to
know what my risk of getting a day it is
this I don't really need to know the
model I just want to know the protection
therefore an alternative way to sort of
think about private learning is as
follows is basically have some kind of
prediction interface which holds the
sensitive data set and we have some
users where each of users can ask for a
prediction on their own points so a user
will send their point and then from this
interface will receive their prediction
for their point and they may ask
additional queries on additional points
and so on and so forth and in this
setting to ensure privacy will require
that this entire trend transcript
satisfies differential privacy with
respect to the sensitive data set in the
usual sense and many of you might notice
that this is actually the way in which
many existing systems already operate
for example if you ask for a credit
score you won't get to see a model or if
you type a search query into a search
engine again you won't get to see the
model that we're predicting based on
whatever
you're putting in so the the other
issues that also now known that this
kind of black box access to learn model
allows one to violate privacy of the
data that has been used for training
there are now several attacks which show
that you can infer whether data point
was using the data set with high
accuracy just on by looking at the
predictions of the model so we need to
ensure privacy and so in this work we
sort of again focus on on accuracy
privacy privacy trade-off and the
perhaps the sort of the simplest
question you would ask in this case is
when understanding this utility price it
to the office what if I are only
interested in single query what kind of
privacy utility trade-off would be
achievable and once you ask it in this
way the model boils down to the
following model which we call difference
with private protection and one says
that the learning algorithm has this
property if a learning algorithm and
query point is depth on differential
private prediction algorithm if for
every query point the prediction of the
algorithm on the data set on this point
satisfies epsilon differential with
privacy with respect to the set penis so
now given this definition you can apply
it to whatever learning problem you're
interested in and we do it for a couple
of problems in the paper so the one
which i think is probably maybe one of
the most interesting ones is the setting
of convex regression and this setting
one has some family of real valued
functions F this capital F which is
parameterized by some W where W in some
is in some convex body in D dimensions
and the goal is to is as follows for
every distribution P over this labeled
appoints the goal is to minimize the
expected work population risk of the
model with respect to some kind of loss
function
and then the true label where and and
the sort of did the saying is convex
which means that the loss of the model
for every serve example the loss of the
model is a convex function of this
parameter W which permit Rises it to
make it a little more concrete will
consider setting where the these convex
functions are one Lipschitz and the set
of models is the l2 ball of radius one
now with the setting which has been well
studied in in learning for example we
know that without privacy you can
achieve excess loss or sub optimality
when optimizing this objective of
roughly 1 over square root of N and it's
optimal if you were to do this with
epsilon differential privacy we know
that you have to pay an additional this
term of D over epsilon n so you have to
pay for the dimension and in our paper
we show that one can in this epsilon
differentially private prediction one
can do it with sample complexity of 1
over square root of epsilon and no it's
also not hard to see that there is an
lower bound of 1 over square root of N
and a 1 over epsilon and and and sort of
the open problem is the gap between
these two bounds and it might not seem
like a big gap but that actually it's a
kind of the same gap as one sees between
the local and the global model
considerably where basically the
question is how much privacy do you get
without any additional increase in the
in the loss what you would serve if
you're aiming for the loss of roughly 1
over square n square root of n then our
upper bound only allows you sort of a
constant epsilon and gives you constant
epsilon for free
whereas we cannot exclude anything which
is better than 1 over square to that so
that's the open problem I don't know do
you have any ok to mean it's wonderful
let me just briefly mention where this
upper bound comes from and also why
maybe one could hope to get a bound like
this so if you look at what's the
sensitivity in this model sensitivity
would correspond roughly to the to this
notion of uniform prediction stability
which is related to uniform stability
which again this will be just basically
what's the definition what is the
sensitivity of this prediction it's
exactly the largest difference between
the values of predictions on two
adjacent data sets so and we would say
that an algorithm satisfy this
prediction stability gamma if this value
is upper bounded by gamma on any pair of
adjacent data sets in any prediction
point X and what's known about this this
notion is that you can you can solve
these convex regression problems with
excess loss of roughly 1 over square
root and which is optimal but also with
stability at the level of 1 over square
root of n so if you want this kind of
just to achieve sensitivity you can do
it with 1 over square root of n so from
this result just by whatever getting
adding Gaussian noise you get our result
I mean in some cases you might need to
first amplify the stability which can be
done in a sort of very simple standard
way by just partitioning the data set
and running whatever there the algorithm
you have on each of the separately and
then just getting their prediction
averaging and and then this will amplify
the stability and then you can get the
result in the entire parameter regime so
yeah that's it actually
any questions
[Applause]
okay so I'm gonna present a kind of a
toy problem to open problems so I'm not
claiming that it has a significant
practical motivation but actually
underline some made a question that is
open which is basically separation
between pure and approximate local
differential price
like whether there is a separation so
the background is using really small
phones here so suppose we have a finite
domain of arbitrary size but it's finite
and without loss of generality it's
simply the set of numbers from 1 to T
and considered a private distributed set
of n users X 1 to X n coming from the
set now like in the local setting ah we
know we want to there is a non trusted
entity you want to evaluate the certain
function think of the Sun and in only
solicit in order certain acquire
destructive local randomizations or like
randomized versions of of the user
inputs and then try to kind of aggregate
them in a clever way to estimate this Q
of s with as much like with as small as
possible in the best possible case and
here the local randomization are defined
basically in the sense so we say that X
1 a randomizer a randomized algorithm
are they private if for all possible
input States the next time from the
domain and all possible multiple sets of
the output range the English induce
distribution by these two pairs of
inputs are closing the usual excellent
of the sense and we say that this
localization is pure Epsilon if Delta is
you it's not talking
okay better definitely okay so well in
the non interactive or offline setting
when this query is published and all the
users knows about it beforehand there is
a result that shows that any epsilon if
you give me any epsilon Delta local
differentially protocol I can transform
it into a pure episode of depression
oh this was the been shown but that had
been shown in a really nice result by
Pam Nelson stammer in 2018 and sort of
the seat of the swap was actually in a
toilet paper with Adam in 2050 so that's
for the non-interactive case for to the
best of my knowledge from my beer on all
the study interactive key settings in
local differential privacy there is no
advantage with no separation between
epsilon Delta and absolute basically can
use this in you know can for every
epsilon dr. differentially local
differential profit protocol we can
device analogous pure epsilon with more
or less the same occurs
so is that problem statement now again
we have a private that should be to
dataset and now I'm going to define
empirical distribution over the dataset
simply the relative frequencies for each
item in the universe and simply let's be
hat askew note the empirical solution
induced by the dataset
now I'm going to define what is called a
linear query over this empirical
distribution and simply it's defined by
some vector Q from R to the T where T
other side of the universe and basically
the objective is to estimate the inner
product between Q and the empirical
distribution not privately I can do it
easily now the goal here is to answer a
sequence of D online wheelies under
local difference primes so by online I
mean that presume it could be the case
that the queries are fixed at the server
side but the user doesn't get to see
query Q J plus 1 until it actually
responds to the other query Q J so there
is this online sequence and for every QJ
users instantiate their local
randomizers on Q J and their inputs and
send some reports and then the server
the untrusted entity would estimate a
provide an estimate for this inner
product and then it proceed to the next
phase where it publish q j plus 1 now
let me make this kind of little bit
contrived assumption suppose that I'm
gonna denote Q I'm gonna let let this
capital kill denote the matrix whose
rows is a queries the degrees
and so the rows of this matrix is
published one at a time and it's let's
suppose that there is an l2 norm
constraint on the columns of these
metrics so basically each column of Q is
bounded in the l2 norm by some R and
this R is published beforehand everybody
knows about but not about the quiz
homes done so the inner criterion you
can imagine in the scenario it could be
the l2 arrow or little infinity air it's
fine doesn't matter so basically l2
error would be simply the sum of squares
of you know the error between the
estimate at each step and the true
output or to the true value of the
linear query you can also consider
another variant so there like that
infinity error now there is a simple
epsilon Delta LD protocol that achieve
roughly about D by n error two squared
here by l2 error I mean l2 squared since
R is known basically what you can do is
for every query every user would simply
look at you know the index in in the
query that that corresponds to his input
and simply add the Scout she knows and
the gal she knows doesn't really depend
on anything except R and of course the
epsilon-delta part and by the you know
properties of the Gaussian distribution
this particular symmetric then it really
doesn't this this this protocol does not
really or this setting there's not
really distinguished between the online
case in the offline case this protocol
would work also you know can presumably
can work in the offline case and it can
work the same protocol would work in the
online case where you see one clear at
the time question is simply either pure
epsilon LDP protocol for the same
setting with same accuracy
I mean this sitting it doesn't seem that
all the sort of the transformation that
we know doesn't work in the city because
of that because online nature there
might be other problems we can make
perhaps kind of indicate the possibility
of having a separation also between us
but the underlying question is like
either separation the upper bound
rely on composition here no it just
depends on like if you if you compile
this protocol the flying case what you
would do is like you would add a
Gaussian like D dimensional Gaussian
vector whose variance about
it's like for a second
that's why you left
it only party
hello sir my name is Sofia Raskolnikov
ah and I will talk about nuts on you
open problem so it's been open for a few
years so maybe it's time that we make
some progress on it it's about local
filters and it's based on joint work
with my dad Jack who is now at Amazon so
the problem the open problem is about
local filters so let me first motivated
so it's filters or a constructor
filtering or construction of C Lipchitz
functions so imagine that we're in the
usual centralized model scenario so we
have individuals will have a trusted
server we have some clients and the
clients want to compute some function on
the database and we would like to work
on it maybe in the blackbox manner so
they send the function in the form maybe
of a program to the trusted server and
the trusted server outputs the value of
the function on the database plus nodes
right so for example this is how the
plasma kinsman works or derivative
mechanisms like mechanisms based on
Lipschitz extensions so
the question is how can we ensure that
this function is really a selection so
what if this client sends the program
and claims that it has Lipschitz
constant C so in principle if we know
that it has literate sponsor constants
equal you know what this program is we
can easily release it but what if we
actually are not sure and would like to
verify it somehow or ensure that it's
true so what can we do
so one relevant object here is from the
field of something elegans which is
called the local ER constructor also
local filter so they were defined with
respect to other properties by alone at
all and Saxon Seshadri specifically this
local model and so this is kind of the
simplest version of this local filter so
and I'm going to explain it in using the
example of significance functions so so
we we expect to see see Lipschitz
function in our application right so
basically the X functionality we expect
is that we send X to the function Norah
call it sends us back f of X but it
might not be the case that this function
f has a desired property that it's
indeed C Lipchitz so what we can do to
ensure that C Lipschutz we put a filter
between the user and the function ok and
then now the user is going to send the
query to the filter instead of sending
it directly to the worker for the
function and what the filter can do it
can make several queries hopefully not
too big not large and not a very large
number of course to the function and get
back the answers and now it's going to
think for a little bit and output
something so let's call it G of X so in
the simplest version so who would like
to make sure is so G of G of X I'm just
going to define it as the output of the
filter on input X right so we would like
to ensure can win the simplest version
is that G is selections and
we need another condition to make a
nontrivial EEP F was already seen
Lipschitz where I'm going to change it
so G has two people to hate so this is
the simplest version of the film filter
so the way I defined it is deterministic
but two things fine randomized version
okay so and then it's and it's easy to
see how we would use it so the client
would send the program program app and
also the Lipschitz constant C and then
we would run the appropriate filter the
trusted server will just run it figure
out this function G evaluated X and this
is what it would release using the cost
mechanism or malicious extensions so
this is a new world and the question is
how good you can make those filters wait
so basically this mechanism is obviously
differentially private and if what the
client provides is actually syllabus
function we have the same accuracy as in
the original so and the running time is
dominated by the running time of the
filter so the question is how fast you
can make it so we had so we're willing
people which we define this problem so
we had the filter so for this space but
you can think about other metric spaces
so what we had is an upper bound on the
running time which is actually
exponential in the dimension D and it
turns out that you need exponential
dependence on the dimension D even for
filters with additive error so basically
I didn't define it but the editor I said
that when F is equal so f is a has
already already has the property then
we're just actually not going to make
any error but even if you allow some
significant it is a curve you need
exponential dependence on T so what do I
want
so like what why am I talking to so
basically it turns out that the lower
bound does not apply in some cases where
we can still get good
good differentially private mechanisms
so if the output function can be knots
ellipses with small probability then the
lower bound doesn't apply right so and
we still can get epsilon-delta
mechanisms using such error constructor
so this one is not the case it doesn't
apply is one given silly is Lipschitz
function we are construct to be
Lipschitz function so it shows the
constant and if we change it by at least
a factor of 2 then the lower bound
doesn't apply yet so and again if we had
a constructor in this case you would
still be useful right so we're still
we're adding some noise anyway so we
could maybe modify the value of the
function a little bit also or maybe not
so that's the question so can we will
avoid exponential dependence on Z with a
write relaxation right so you can think
about relaxing in terms of be relaxing
in terms of the probability or maybe
even just some subset of the domain on
which you can do it so if we can do this
it could be really useful for ensuring
in the systems that programs that run
are actually see Lipchitz and as a
result we can get differentially private
mechanism is using them as a black box
so that so and I guess more generally
maybe we can just combine this with some
program verification methods to
new business and privacy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry are there any lower bounds maybe
like sub-exponential indeed for this
case so for this case is a no so there
is only this this lower bound is quite
involved so it's like a pancake roof
yeah so and for this case of error okay
so now we've known on Tortola robots
[Music]
the problem is if we can use instead of
directly adding noise you have both
westerlies Meccans so which act checks
are blow off on this - sure sensitivity
is small locally so you're saying maybe
let's modify the object somehow so it's
not the filter okay I need a mechanism
that we'll be using on top of it instead
of just directly well possibly can do a
lot of course maybe some kind of lose
the localization yeah oh yeah just
something from which local sensitivity
are small sensitivity will suffice
right so so I guess we can think what
would be the right object so so stalks
tracked out exactly what we need from
that way - so you you could have like a
more relaxed object ah but that's easier
to remember to Westar
that's with Thomas okay so some of you
have probably heard me talk about this
product before if you're sick of me
talking about it I solve it and I'll
stop so let me let me stop with it
sitting telling you about the most basic
problem which is you're given some
function takes input and outputs a real
number and it has sensitivity 1 all
right and your task is to output this
subject to say epsilon the French
privacy we know exactly what the result
is the expected error between Europe
algorithm and the true answer that is
gonna be okay great so that's fun we
understand this on this being in the
literature since 2006 so let me tell you
about that like but also the second most
basic problem in differential privacy so
now you have a whole bunch of query so
query 1 up to query K and you want to
release all of those now let's say
instead of just the error of one thing
we're looking like the AL infiniti era
of the the vector of answers and victor
so under pure differential privacy we
know they need to have a dependence on
the the dimension the number of series K
so that's something that we don't know
but we also know that we can do better
than that if we relaxed to something
like epsilon Delta DP or like where to
concentrate the DP but this we have
following result
so if you add so this is just adding
applause or Gaussian noise and if you
just add independent or placer Gaussian
noise to each individual query and you
apply composition result you'll get an
upper bound that looks like this
see a square root K because getting
bitter composition under these relaxed
notions of differential privacy where is
this squared log K coming from
that's just a Union bound because he
hadn't K samples from Gaussian noise the
worst of those because of the cell
affinity era is going to be walk a worse
than that this one and then the average
I almost have a lower bound which is
root K over Epsilon
okay so you'll notice that there's a gap
here so there's a there's no long K on
the lower bound there is a log K in the
upper bound and you may be wondering now
which of these is correct so I have a
partial answer which is basically a
bitter upper bound
turn that wall k into a log log k now
you know if there's any justice in the
universe that means we can remove it
entirely k beats not stand a bit closer
so see I have a bounty on this I think
if you like remove it or buy you dinner
if if you prove a lower bound that has
like a log log or a log star many of
your drinks okay so that's the same
another problem basically here's a gap
let's let's resolve it how much time do
I have can I like say a little bit more
about two minutes okay so how do these
algorithms work so the way this
algorithm works is you just add
independent Gaussian noise and you can
say well you know most of these answers
are actually gonna be good there's gonna
be a handful of answers like one of a
poet you know a inverse probably
logarithmic fraction of the answers
gonna be bad and it turns out that I can
kind of find these guys and fix them
using like the exponential mechanism
response vector so we can actually go
back and fix these bad answers and
that's where you get this log log from
so you just need to make sure you get
most of them right and then you can go
back and fix them this is kind of a
messy algorithm I would really love to
have an algorithm and it's just a clean
noise adding distribution this algorithm
is a noise any distribution but you have
to like really look closely to see it so
if you manage to get rid of the log log
with a really clean noise heading
distribution I will buy you dinner and
drinks but I think those are the rules
buck do you get the rules that I added
in the chapter on the web sites on the
web socket you can look up the terms and
conditions
yeah so I'm just gonna pretend that
we're using concentrated DP so you just
multiply by root log 1 of a delta to get
there something else so there's no
interesting dependence as far as I know
on Delta
oh yes so if you just use l2 around one
error then it's all to the lower bound
this type of it so it's the same lower
bound for thank Thomas my man
yes I'm just gonna check
okay I also refused to take slides so I
just wanted to do maybe a little bit of
an advertising I don't know if how far
privacy has gone in this area but this
is just you can just sort of think of
this as basically like optimal smoothing
with privacy it's sort of my general
curiosity so I'm biased in the sense
that I have particular smoothing
problems I'm most interested in so I'll
just list the one that I find that I
care the most about but so they're set
up basically as follows so suppose that
I give you data following so I wrote
this I had this on my slides the other
day for you so I have data from some
subject I but I observe that subject at
different domain locations so I think a
lot about time but it could be other
sorts of spaces all right and so that
data is equal to some function right
plus some noise
so you hear this is the mean function
this is what you want to estimate
okay and so the t's right so I'm going
to just say they're in some script II
set and that so that can be a nice
subset of Rd right so this can be subset
Rd or it can even be like a compact
Romanian manifold if you want to go that
route so but anyways if in either of
those cases we know how to actually
estimate this thing in an optimal sense
but not not with privacy so the
Epsilon's those are subject-specific
errors
okay and so these guys we usually think
of them as being relatively smooth
deviations and so you can even have iid
noise on top if you want something like
Delta IJ so that could be like iid noise
just iid and every possible that's
alright
so the sort of cleanest way I know of
estimating this and getting some sort of
tight rates is to use reproducing kernel
Hilbert spaces okay so this is okay so
I'm just gonna quickly write this down
and then I'll I'll say what the best
rate is I know up for I'll say what the
best rate is without privacy and then
just sort of leave the privacy question
open so if you want to define an arc HS
then you need a kernel right so this
thing needs to be symmetric and
positive-definite right once you have
that I just a decisions I would have to
really explain this so maybe maybe I
don't even explaining here but anyways
so if you want to generate the arc HS
than what you need to do is you take
some set which consists of all
combinations
so you basically take some set where you
you take this kernel function you
evaluate it at some domain locations to
you I you take all possible sort of
linear combinations this is sort of a
fairly nice set so this I can choose any
a eyes and any domain locations but only
up dimension n okay I then equipped that
set with the inner product alright so
the inner product of like f1 and f2 this
is the sum over AI 1 AI 2
okay so I can form an inner product for
this set right and now once I have an
ear product then I get I can complete it
right and so the completion of this set
and so completion of a this is okay and
that's that's the arc HS
there's a few other ways you can
generate them but that's one way of
doing it right so you basically start
with some sort of nice functions you
have an inner product and you complete
okay all right
so if this mu is inside of this are an
arc HS then we know what the optimal
estimation rate is right and so if so if
mu is in sake a right so by that I mean
let's in like some nice ball and K
greats not why not - hey then the
optimal rate is the following I think
some estimator - the truth square it and
integrate it okay over the center and
then that rate is it's up I'm a
statistician we deal a lot with Opie's
so I'm going to LP so this is Big O P of
a 1 over n plus 1 over n m 2h over 2 h
LS 1 okay and the H the H is determined
by how quickly the eigenvalues of this
kernel function decay so if you do start
like a spectral expansion of this guy
how quickly those eigenvalues decay
so the thing the sort of weird thing
here is that you get something so in
statistics we call this a parametric
rate of convergence and when M is one we
call this a non parametric rate of
convergence and so the interesting thing
is that you get sort of both depending
on so what is M so the J is C of n
subjects and M domain P yeah this one
that's probability it's Big O P so Big O
in probability oh I know you guys love
these like this so yet so it's to say
that this is this is a random variable
and this gives you the convergence and
probability that's the best right so so
then basically the question is if you if
you want to do this with privacy what
happens to the rate
and dimension you would expect only
showed up through edge the dimension oh
so so if so the little trick here is
that ages can be written like R over D
where R is the number of derivatives for
the functions and D is the dimension so
that's so we'll have spaces of this kind
are special types of Arc HSS
[Applause]
okay so this is a problem that I
recently thought of and it hasn't really
been tested so let's see if someone
solves it now or in the coffee break
this is about selection which is I think
a basic problem of sort of private
optimization
it's about repeated selection so let me
describe what I mean
so selection means that you have some
number of low sensitivity queries you
want to select the ones that have the
largest value let's restrict ourselves
to say counting quickly so let's say you
given M counting queries
let me call them q1 to kill em and maybe
let me write this as a set that's a
disease q all right so I guess I want -
but County queries each of them is given
by a predicate and it's counting how
much what's the fraction of things in
the database that satisfies the
predicate and we also given of course a
database which I'll call X and let's say
this lives in some universe to the end
so anytime a database and the goal is to
select the K queries with the gaze of
the primary have because to select the K
queries with the largest value so you
want to output some subset s of the
queries such that let me see how I
formulated this such that nothing
outside of this set is too much bigger
than anything inside of this set so this
is my notion of approximation so I say
for every I in s and for every J not in
s I want that the value of Q I database
X is at least the value of Q J on X
minus alpha so alpha is an approximation
okay so if alpha was zero this would
exactly be maybe slightly complicated
way to say that it should be the top K
queries and now I'm allowing error alpha
from no condition and the size of this
set if you can take all all or nothing
Hey
okay thanks
okay that is that now mixes
how can we solve this I basically know
two algorithms one sound silly but they
actually could be better depending on Q
so the basic question is maybe before I
describe the algorithms the basic
question is for each Q what is the
smallest and so that I can solve this
problem which is sort of example
complexity smallest n which this is
solvable with let's say your favorite
notion of privacy so let's say epsilon
Delta differential privacy this is the
basic question again the way I've asked
it I'm asking if I give you the queries
what is the best algorithm that you can
use for those queries so the answer may
depend on what the queries are we sort
of know the answer if we want to know
what is the best thing to do for sort of
the worst possible queries okay so now
let me tell you what are the two
algorithms that I didn't know for this
so one is do either so these are
algorithms
what algorithm is do report noisy max or
exponential mechanism K times K times
and let's say analyze it with advanced
composition and then basically whatever
Q is if you're running this algorithm
the sample complexity is that n should
be at least something like root K root
log of 1 over Delta if you doing episode
of the differential privacy times log m
and is the total number of queries again
over let's say alpha epsilon and this is
as far as I know tight for Q equals all
one-way marginals
and honest and correct me if I'm wrong
okay so this is sometimes the right
thing to do
another thing you can do is just compute
all the queries so come to compute Q 1
of X 2 Q M of X and I won't write it but
select the top okay based on computing
all of them and this could sometimes be
better so for example imagine that Q is
threshold queries or histogram queries
so for histogram queries computing all
the queries is better than this right so
this sometimes actually beats the
algorithm that I think makes more sense
but ok it's not always optimal and maybe
a more constrained version of this more
general question is I'm not I cannot
think of any example for example meaning
an example of an algorithm and queries I
guess for natural queries maybe so that
an example guess of algorithm that beats
both on some queue
both 1 & 2 on some nice cube let's see 1
minutes okay I don't think I have
anything else to say so maybe I'll take
a question
so you're thinking of casting small and
the other parameters becoming larger
yeah maybe
sure
I okay so no actually not necessarily so
what it was what I was saying is that
this can sometimes be better this is I
guess if K is like a little bit large so
let's say all threshold queries we can
compute with sample complexity which is
something like 2 to the log star if
alpha is constant and then if K is like
bigger than 2 to the log starting it's
like log then this is already better
actually looking at this there's a log
there anyway so maybe I didn't need to
do a whole thing so maybe you think of K
is being smaller than the other
parameters but still going to infinity
so maybe one set of queries for which I
don't quite yeah I can
let's save the queries here have some
some notion of like small VC dimension
that does that help in some way
[Music]
[Applause]
let's not really leave this here than
that well because you look so weird
daddy just real tuned
okay so I'll talk about I'll credit sort
of two papers by Sam elder for
formulating this problem and saying some
of the things we know know about it so
this isn't really a problem about
privacy although many of the same people
work on it and many the same techniques
come up this many of you know so that's
why it makes sense to talk about it
here's it but but the problem itself
doesn't explicitly talk about privacy
mentioned we've got a data set called X
it consists of n records drawn iid from
some distribution P so he's a
distribution along some universe u X is
PI D and copies we hand this this this
data set to some mechanism and this
mechanism is going to try to answer
queries about the data from that are
coming from some analyst
and specifically these are statistical
areas or if you prefer you know for
simplicity counting queries so each each
query is specified by a function from
the universe to zero one and this could
be either 0 or 1 if you prefer and now I
they're sort of two relevant directly
relevant notions here there's the answer
to the query the on the data set so
given a data set X the value of the
query is the empirical mean of Q over
over the data points and but then I can
also talk about the valley of the query
on the distribution and that's the
expected value of this function a fresh
sample from people so the mechanisms
goal is to produce answers such that for
all for all i from
102k the the difference between the
provided answer and the true population
answer is small so so the ant mechanism
is going to try to provide answers that
are useful in as much as they reflect
the population which may not be the same
as answers that reflect the value on the
data set and so we can ask like what's
the best mechanism for this and and and
we'll often for convenience if we want
sort of things that work for all
analysts tools are put on our computer
scientist hats and think of the analyst
as an adversary here and so what we want
to know is I'm gonna look at for a given
mechanism and with what we want us to be
able to say is something like for all
distributions P and for all adversaries
ever all analysts a the probability that
the maximum error is at most alpha is
let's say you know 99 percent for
example you could require and it could
pass for the expected maximum to be
small the expected square whatever you
want and so this what this says is that
the so we want to find a mechanism for
which this quantity is small so what we
really want is like the you know does
there exist a mechanism that solves this
and what we want is the art men over
alpha of this quantity and we have
various upper bounds and lower bounds on
these quantities they're they're
reasonably close there's some small gaps
there what we don't know is we don't
know sort of non-trivial impossibility
results for this side
where we need when we just make a small
change the quantifiers of the setting
which is that we give the mechanism
access to the same information that the
analyst has about the distribution so
let me explain that just a little bit so
one can imagine that there's some sort
of generation algorithm that's some some
some process that's generating the
underlying population and in the worst
this sort of class of the the setup that
I had before it's equivalent to say I
want you know the accuracy no matter how
he is generated but now I could I can
ask what happens if both the mechanism
and the analyst know this generation
know the description of this generation
process so they know the same like prior
they have the same prior on the
distribution and what that corresponds
to in terms of quantifiers is just
swapping the first first two quantifiers
so we could ask for the kind of
symmetric version of this where we just
say what we want is that for for all
generating distributions there exists a
mechanism that now might depend on the
generate on the prior such that you know
for all adversaries for all analysts the
same thing happens and again we might
ask for a sort of the the best rate for
with the best error for which this is
possible this is a function because this
one case this is going to be a function
and and the number of queries in both
cases so this is the first one is sort
of an asymmetric setting and the second
one is a completely symmetric setting
and essentially the open question is to
find non-trivial lower bounds on the
second quantity so some things are known
and I can tell you offline more about
what what is known but in full
generality we don't know anything that
doesn't that isn't sort of just true
that true for non adaptively posed
queries and all something yeah you can
get allowed to depend on the prior look
it's not doesn't have to hold university
you can also ask for prior specific
balance that's right although those I
think we know more about but you mean
for specific priors oh sorry so here
what's going on is that the mechanism
known that what is the mechanism get to
see the mechanism only sees yes only the
oh no no no Jenny help the distribution
so Jen is not the distribution that's
like on prior of our distribution so
imagine it's a process that generates a
sample PE from I sample a description of
the population so it's a prior
distribution over populations and now
what I want is that that so is yes so
the mechanism needs to look at the data
but now the we're allowing the mechanism
to know the same thing that the analyst
does about so where is it this setup
over here if you sort of think of this
game theoretically the these two players
are playing together against the
mechanism so they're sort of jointly
selecting the adversarial the analyst
strategy and the probability
distribution at the same time and it
turns out that gives the this kind of
pair of players a lot of power over the
mechanism
we know how to prove lower bounds so
Stein Ken Ulman have the strongest
result in that setting
but once we switch this we know some
like Park under lots of assumptions we
can say different things but like we
don't really have a strong okay so I'm
out I'm still fun and problem I'd like
to talk about is about all Paris
distances under differential primacy so
so if you have a graph one of the basic
functions that you might want to compute
is the distance between pair of vertices
under the normal notions of differential
privacy for graphs no differential
privacy edge differential privacy this
doesn't make a lot of sense because you
can delete a single edge and make a
distance go from 1 2 and minus 1 or you
can even disconnect the graph so if
we're trying to hide the topology of the
graph it doesn't make a lot of sense to
ask for to ask for distances but what
what does make sense is to consider a
setting where the topology of the graph
is is is fixed and publicly known and
the private information consists of an
edge wave function
and then we're trying to we're trying to
compute distances in a weighted graph
and in the weighted graph so if we
restrict to the setting so so then the
next question is what at what our
neighboring weight functions so sort of
one very natural choice is to say that
that two weight functions are neighbors
if they differ by at most one in L one
arm so that that'll be the definition
we'll use and to do this definition
releasing a single distance is is
completely trivial it's a sensitivity
one query but the question we can ask is
what if we want to release the
approximate distance between all pairs
of vertices in a graph so that so then
we have N squared queries and there's
two very natural approaches like the
first the first two things you try would
be you have N squared queries we can do
them each privately its composition so
that gives error roughly n log 1 over
Delta over epsilon
and the other very natural thing to do
is to take take each edge and a blue
plus noise to the weight of the edge
sort of relief synthetic data and
compute distances in that synthetic
graph and that gives our something like
n log n of epsilon so in both cases
so for these you know simple approaches
we're getting air linear and N and I
have no idea if that's inherent or not
so the question is does this have to be
linear and
can we come up with an algorithm that's
that that doesn't have this dependence
on an orc or is there a lower bound I
what lower bounds come again I don't
know a non-trivial lower bound maybe we
can have a lower bound of N or something
weaker that would be interesting I
should also mention that I do know for
two special classes of graphs we can do
better so so for trees we can do sort of
exponentially better all-pairs distances
in trees we can get our roughly log to
the one point five and over Epsilon and
I suspect this can be improved to log n
this is very much analogous to releasing
all threshold queries which sort of
corresponds to two two distances in the
path graph so we can generalize that to
arbitrary trees and then the other
setting is is if we have four guaranteed
that the that the weights are bounded
then we can get air that it looks like
[Music]
sort of root n times M
and I also don't know if this is if this
is optimal or if we or if there's
interesting balance for other classes of
graphs any questions so for bounded
weight I think it's something like
basically you can find a without looking
at the weights you can find a set of
vertices basically if you just look at a
graph you can find some set of vertices
so that every vertex is not too far from
one vertex if so you find you choose
some set s of the vertices that's not
too large so that every vertex in the
graph is not far from a vertex of s and
then the distances between vertices and
s give you a pretty good approximation
for distances in the graph and then you
can sort of tune the size of s to make
it work out
if you don't care about the better if
you don't care about computational
efficiency I have no idea the the
algorithms I know are efficient but but
there might be something better there
isn't